good evening and welcome to the historic
Woolsey Hall on the Yale University
campus on behalf of our distinguished
guests faculty students staff and
Friends assembled in this Hall I welcome
the Yale Community throughout the world
who join us in this musical salute to
president salv by live video
stream from Yale's founding service in
1701 to the present day music has
permeated this
place 25 to 30% of Yale's students
participate in scores of curricular and
and extracurricular music activities
these groups range from AC capella
singing to Baroque Opera from Jazz
ensembles to a Russian course that began
60 years ago from Residential College
orchestras to a gamalon
society all that is Yale is illumined by
our
music A celebratory Fan Fair best begins
an inaugural concert
and this evening Mr President Professor
Thomas Duffy has composed one of these
fanf fairs in your honor the circle
Fanfare thoughtfully conceived and
crafted by this composer the Fanfare
also asked our University organist
Thomas Murray to respond to the
ensemble's located around the
hall perhaps there's some inherent
symbolism in this for you Mr
President careful study careful planning
will always require some confident
improvisation from
you ladies and gentlemen join me in
welcoming Professor Thomas Duffy
composer conductor and distinguished
University
citizen
for
Yale was almost 100 years old when
France Joseph heyen began work on his
inspiring oratorio the
creation the Reverend Timothy Dwight IV
was then president of
Yale drawing from three textural sources
the biblical books of Genesis and Psalms
and Milton's Paradise
Lost heyen composes a masterful work
depicting God's creation of the
world the music reveals hidden sense of
wonder at God's
handywork now two centuries after the
first performance of this work Yale is a
rare dwelling place for Wonder in our
firmament here we find inspiration and
the courage to create to discover to
incessantly ask why and why
not please join me in welcoming our
soloist and Margaret Brooks conductor of
the Yale camarada to the
podium
the glor
of
that
is night that is gone
to night the night that is gone
to
night
all the
land never unive
ever
un
Ood
ever
unod ever
the
our
guitar music has enjoyed a long and
vibrant history at Yale next to voice
and piano the guitar in its many
manifestations has been the most popular
musical instrument
graduates from the El School of Music
guitar program have gone on to have
Sterling International careers and have
been leaders in the field of pedagogy at
both University and high school levels
the group tonight consists of current
students and graduates hailing from
Australia Uruguay Germany Canada Armenia
and the United
States the two selections we are about
to hear tonight reflect the versatility
and adaptability of the instrument
whether Europe during the Baroque or the
Brazil of today the guitar expresses a
voice and a culture that is personal
even intimate ladies and gentlemen
internationally renowned artist Ben
verter and the Yale
guitars
for
you
B
he
Martin the next selection honors
you clearly your role in Yale's new
presidential chapter is one for which we
thank you in
advance it seems appropriate then that
the Glee Club Yale's most venerable
music group at 153 years should sing to
you you will hear these
words when the breeze of winter slips
through my window I hear a sound as if
an angel with the hands of silk on my my
bells plays a
mcal t t tan here how beautiful is the
Talen of my crystal bells toen tillen
ton bells that play for me such a sweet
song laugh laugh laugh beautiful crystal
bells that brighten my hours of pain
ring ring ring only for me little
crystal
bells the yo Glee Club ladies and
gentlemen directed by Jeff
Dalma
spee
fore
as your program indicates Paul Jacobs
won a Grammy in
2010 but you will also be interested to
know that he won the very first Grammy
ever awarded in classical organ
performance in his extensive repertoire
are the complete organ works of JS Bach
and Max
reager yes Paul Jacobs is a prodigious
talent and tonight he performs the music
of another Prodigy Mozart and he asked
that following the Mozart there be no
applause Mr President a commencement is
a new beginning and virtually everyone
in this Hall who has graduated from
kindergarten through graduate school has
marched to Pomp and
Circumstance which as your program also
indicates first filled this Hall many
years ago so tonight led by Paul Jacobs
we march with you to the New Horizons
where you will take us with a
vision and our work together on behalf
of this great
institution join me in welcoming Paul
Jacobs
home
for
e
I
in 1879 brahs received an honorary
doctorate from the University of
Presa the music faculty member who
nominated him according to
Folklore suggested hinted that brahs
write a substantial work as a proper
thank you for this honorary
degree of course there was was not to be
a fee um he was to be given or had been
given actually the honorary doctrate so
brahs decided he would do
this tonight we're going to hear
academic Festival over tour and in
brom's hand and with his pin it was
academic his extraordinary compositional
techniques weave together a number of
ideas but what he does with these ideas
is integrate student drinking
songs there's a certain balance that is
important in a
university that's what Thursday nights
are about here from what I
understand so Brahms had the last laugh
and the honorary
degree the Yale Phil harmonia Orchestra
from the School of Music along with
members of the incredible Yale Symphony
Orchestra under the Baton of the Yale
Symphony conductor Toshi shamata bring
us brahms's academic Festival over tour
Maestro Shamar and the
orchestra
e
you
all
that's okay I was trying to think about
what I was going to say about
Aldo the yellos have thrilled audiences
all over the world among their alumni
just to name a few principal chalis in
the New York field
and the newest chist in the New York
fil college President Ronald
Crutcher this distinguished concert
artist Juan Jinn and just scores of
chist who hold University professorships
and Orchestra positions on several
continents throughout the
world Aldo paraso is the Sanford
professor of
cello following a long and Brilliant
career at as a chist who played in every
major major capital of the world under
the leading conductors of that time he
turned to teaching where for the last
several decades he has become known as
one of a very few teachers the most
elite in his
profession
1958 was a very m magical year in Yale
history in
1958 Aldo paraso joined the Yale faculty
he is the longest serving member of
Yale's
faculties in
1958 Peter salv was
born seriously though I mean Peter is a
musician Aldo is the longest serving
faculty member this seems appropriate to
me ladies and gentlemen the Beloved
director of the Yale cellos Aldo
parison
w
Gra
la
e
Yale has had presidents who acknowledged
music Yale has had presidents who
supported music Yale has had presidents
who appreciated
music yel has had at least one president
that I know who has understood and loved
music now Yale has a president who per
performs music what is happening to
us
somewhere somewhere Plato is really
scratching his head trying to think this
one through now travel back with me to
Tom Duffy's Fanfare you heard some
unusual
instrumentation you heard clarinets
there was a reason for that Peter's
musical Journey began with the study of
clarinet but as he became more and more
sophisticated and developed he became a
double Bas Bluegrass
player what are the odds that any
president of an internationally
distinguished research University
performs bluegrass music anywhere what
are the odds of that now our are in the
future this would be an interesting bet
to take Peter I think you're the only
one and you may have thought you might
have gotten through this without your
own special tribute but I kind of gave
you a hint that something was going to
happen about this but before we get to
that last week I had a call from a dean
of a major
Conservatory who suggested to me me that
once again Yale has kind of stepped out
in front he said that now we have the
perfect model for a senior professor in
music as seen in our
President we have someone who raises
money we have a Performing Artist and we
have a psychologist who studied
emotional
Wellness we have in our new president uh
a person
that we all relate to on any number of
levels because in his own
way he meets people where he is and at
the very best of what music is that is
precisely what it does Peter we take
great pleasure in the joy you derive
from making
music and it would really be
Unthinkable to Omit a Bluegrass Tribute
to the to you this evening
one of your professors of Bluegrass is
here to play a special tribute to you
anybody here from California knows that
Tanga Canyon is a well-known destination
what you probably don't know is that in
the
1970s they had a well-known banjo
contest and our artist tonight is the
winner the first prize winner of course
it was in 1972 of the tapanga canyon
banjo
contest more recently in addition to his
night job as professor of Bluegrass he
has a day job here at Yale as professor
of
Psychiatry I want you to join me in
welcoming Oscar Hills who is going to
play Dixie breakdown it is I am sure a
top 10 iTune off their CD picker Parish
Oscar
Hills
e
make our garden grow is the final number
in Leonard Bernstein's
candid we'll build our house and chop
our wood and make our garden grow
gardening is familiar to Marta and Peter
and now you are the curators of Yale's
Gardens we'll work beside you we'll work
with you we'll work for you tilling soil
fertilizing watering
pruning to make Yale's Gardens grow
bountifully wherever they are
planted the camarada the Glee Club the
orchestras two wonderful soloists join
Jeff Dalma as he conducts this wonderful
piece from
candid
a
fool and so have
I but
come and be
my and let
usy
we
make some sense of
life
good
the we'll build our
house and chop our
and
make and make
a
my
the best
we we'll build
a and CH
wood and
make
you have been a wonderful audience and
it has been everyone's pleasure who has
participated in this program tonight
Marta and Peter to give you this sendoff
gift as as you begin this new chapter of
your lives in a moment we're going to
conclude this assembly as only we should
with bright college Years but I'm going
to ask all of the conductors and
soloists to join us on the stage and in
front I know you're going to want to
thank them and all of these musicians
one more time and of course they want to
participate as well in bright College
Years but before I ask them to come back
there are so many people to
thank
and there is no way to call names but
I'm going to ask one person to come out
and accept all of your thanks and ours
for making this evening possible at the
risk of my own
life our producer Christa Johnson has
given heart and soul to make this
evening so wonderful and if I can get
some the string Bas players to drag her
out here please give her your
thanks and now our soloist our
conductors our other performers and
these wonderful musicians with us but we
invite our soloist and conductors back
to the stage for bright college
Years they're looking for their
handkerchiefs
the arrangement of right college
Years Mr President was especially done
in your honor tonight by Colin Brit it's
a new arange arrangement of Bri college
Years for orchestra organ and
chorus before we sing I'm going to ask
for the house lights to come up because
the musicians and all of us in the
audience want to ask Peter and Marta to
stand and let us thank you Peter
Marta
ch
Earth
all
I
see
yeah